India fue el peor ataque terrorista en
la historia de nuestro país. Parece
algo tan fácil de hacer para un político que
denunció a Alvin amamantando a Parmar,
ampliamente reconocido como el autor intelectual del
atentado con bomba de Air India, pero tomó meses
como líder del NDP para carne de jarra. Singh  para hacer
eso
, si no condena la glorificación
de tubba por debajo de la par cuando él es el
autor intelectual del atentado con bomba de Air India, la
investigación identificada dice específicamente
cuando dicen de nuestra y
acepto los hallazgos de la
investigación de la investigación los
acepto  y condeno a todos los responsables,
por lo que acepta que Avenue Parmar fue
el autor intelectual de Air India. Sí, acepto
los hallazgos de la investigación y ese es uno
de los hallazgos cuando se
le pidió repetidamente a Singh que hiciera esto
hace solo unos meses.
no el atacante. No sé quién
fue el responsable, pero creo que debemos
averiguar quién es el verdadero responsable. En los
últimos días, apareció un video que muestra a Singh
en el asiento.  mítines paratistas con carteles que veneran a
los extremistas violentos como asesinatos
esto sucede en Canadá con Parmar
representado no como un terrorista sino como un
héroe Singh no lo anunciaría antes de
que lo hiciera hoy ¿condenaría el uso
de los carteles de asesinatos en los eventos
personalmente, creo?  la visualización de una
imagen de mr.  Parmar es algo que
alcanza a Ramat Eise y duele y lesiona a las
personas que están sufriendo tanto en
términos de esa pérdida en sus vidas y
no creo que sea apropiado, así que no
creo que deba hacerse uno de los
críticos más duros de Singh llama a esto  buenas pero
retrasadas movidas uno en ambos aspectos Creo
que ha hecho lo correcto mejor Lee
nunca,
pero denunciar los carteles no significa que
Singh boicoteará los eventos en los que
aparecen esos carteles. Dice que muchos sijs quedaron
traumatizados por el ciclo de violencia
que asoló la India  la década de 1980
y provocó miles de muertes diciendo
quiere llegar a las personas que sienten
esa ira y venerar a personas como
Parmar por rabia o no podría ir y
dejar ese espacio vacío para que se hable
para ser ocupado por alguien más que puede
no tiene el mismo mensaje que yo tengo un
mensaje que solo ahora está entregando
públicamente David Cochrane CBC News